foreign
numbers to flesh this out but it seems
to me that we have reached another
period of peak race hustling of course
the race Hustlers are always out there
skulking and crawling about but there
are seasons when they are less active
and then there are seasons when they're
more active much like deer ticks or
other blood-sucking parasitic life forms
in that ebb and flow cycle it would
appear that we are now in a time of flow
the disingenuous tiers of racial self
victimization are certainly flowing as
furiously as they ever have before which
is why over the past few weeks
when it comes time for the daily
cancellation often the toughest choice
is to decide which which racial
grievance-mongering phony I'll focus on
vote today I think there is one who
really stands out from the rest and that
is Mark Curry Mark Curry is a former 90s
sitcom actor who over the last couple of
decades has fallen into near total
obscurity and he now tours the country
as an alleged comedian searching for the
most undiscerning crowds to perform in
front of he's a struggle to gain
attention or publicity through the
strength of his comedy and I'm assuming
that's why he's decided to
just finally cash in his victim tokens
at the prize counter and take what he
can get for them and he has been able to
get
something he's gotten some headlines out
of it he's gotten some pity he'll
probably get a lawsuit here's the story
from NBC News it says comedian Mark
Curry accused a Colorado Hotel staffer
of racially profiling him as he sat in
the lobby an incident that prompted
outrage from celebrities and a promise
from the establishment to refund him
after the actor posted video of the
alleged encounter on Instagram Curry who
starred in ABC's Hanging with Mr Cooper
from 1992-1997 was staying at the Mining
Exchange in Colorado Springs
he was in the city for performances at
three E's comedy club on Friday and
Saturday uh Curry was drinking coffee
when he said the employee asked him if
he was a guest he also informed him the
lobby was Private the comedian said
according to the video NBC News does not
know what happened before Curry started
recording recording
well of course they don't
because one thing we know about almost
any video relating to a supposed racism
controversy is that the video always
picks up in the middle of the exchange
or the incident we're never told what
happened beforehand
um and before we play some of this out
of context video for you here's the
hotel's response NBC news reports again
we are committed to providing a safe and
inclusive space for all guests and
employees the statement read we deeply
regret this incident and have reached
out to Mr Curry to offer not only our
sincere apologies but a full refund of
his stay and an invitation to return at
no cost any time in the future as a
respected Community partner we are also
using this opportunity to revisit
training with our staff helping to
ensure all interactions are reflective
of our company Windham Hotels and
Resorts issued a similar statement The
Mining Exchange is a Windham Hotel quote
the hotel's owner and management team
are working to make this right the
company wrote on Twitter on Sunday
so they deeply regret the incident
and it is indeed regrettable
but not because of the employee's
Behavior
even in spite of the out of context
nature of this video
and the sketchy details about what
exactly precipitated it
we still can clearly identify the bad
guy in this situation
now this goes on for about 25 minutes
but I'll show you about two minutes of
it here's the first two minutes and here
it is
all right so the problem is I'm in a
hotel lobby and this man wants to see
well let me let me see some ID
you got your backup how you doing back
up does he speak yeah
hello back up
John you've been you've been here for 15
minutes
okay where are we gonna put you all
right
people
he was asking me for my I can't be in
the hotel lobby
this hotel lobby you cannot be in this
hotel lobby if you're black and you're a
Colorado's friend so if you're black and
you're Colorado Springs you can't be in
the lobby wow this is crazy isn't it so
check it out
oh yeah
yeah
look they got a black man in Colorado
Springs so they send this dude look yeah
oh yeah the one he talks now he talks
yeah
yeah so a black man can't be
yeah yeah I'm trying to pull a race car
boy so so so we got an Uncle Tom calling
me saying I'm doing the race car but he
but he hanging with this dude this is
what it's all about people
he called me uh the race car
I've asked you very politely what'd you
ask me so I can't hear are you a guest
of the hotel I can't hear you say it
again you heard me I couldn't hear you
my hard of hearing
foreign
that continues for 20 more minutes as
Mark Curry the victim quote unquote
becomes more and more belligerent
shouting and cussing at the hotel
employees who are simply trying to do
their jobs Curry posted this video on
Instagram along with the name of one of
the hotel employees and the hotel's
phone number he sent an angry mob after
the establishment many prominent people
joined in the mob celebrities coming to
Curry's defense expressing their support
for him during this difficult and
traumatic time
and yet anybody with ears and a brain to
go between them can watch this and
clearly see that the bad guy in this
scenario is curry himself
I mean how morally deranged do you have
to be as an individual to watch that
and think that the guy holding the
camera is the good guy
in fact Curry's not only the bad guy but
he's also the racist one in the exchange
he repeatedly mocks one of the hotel
workers who's also black calling him an
Uncle Tom making fun of the way he looks
he is screaming racial slurs of the
hotel staff while claiming to be the
rate the racism victim in the
conversation
and all of this simply because he was
asked if he was a guest at the hotel he
could have answered and said yes
and the conversation would have been
over
that's all you had to do
instead he turned this low stakes
totally normal interaction into a
30-minute argument and entered the
30-minute argument into a national
backlash
that automatically makes him not only
the bad guy here but an a-hole of
gargantuan proportions
and the fact that he's doing all this to
some random low-paid service industry
workers only makes him even more of a
sociopath by the way I have at least
twice in my life okay I'll go on the
record
twice in my life at least I have been
approached by staff members at a hotel
and asked a similar question on one
occasion I was sitting in a hotel lobby
and I was asked whether I was a guest
and the answer was no because I was
actually just there to steal their Wi-Fi
to be honest on another occasion the
answer was was yes I was a guest and uh
and I was innocent of any crime on both
occasions I I simply answered the
question
that's it I wasn't interested in getting
into an argument with Hotel employees I
didn't see it as a publicity opportunity
and even though I was slightly
embarrassed on the first occasion when I
was essentially thrown out I had no
desire to exact Vengeance or send an
angry mob after them
neither incident seemed you know
important or interesting to me which is
why I never mentioned them until just
now
it's true that hotel workers in my
experience normally won't ask you what
you're doing in the lobby but if you sit
in enough hotel lobbies you'll likely be
questioned at least once or twice in
your life
in Mark Curry's case considering how
shocked and offended he was we can
assume that this was the first time he'd
ever encountered this line of
questioning
so when he says oh black man can't go
anywhere in America well according to
you you could go anywhere you've never
this is the first time this has ever
happened to you which why you make us a
big deal out of it
which means in the anecdotal comparison
by the way I have had this experience
twice as many times as he has
the only difference is that I don't have
a reflexive racial filter to feed every
experience through
so if somebody says something to me
whatever it is
I don't immediately think hey he just
said that to a white man
I don't think that okay instead I think
hey he just said that to me
do you see the difference now I am of
course aware that I'm a white man I'm
happy to be a white man because that's
part of my identity I'm proud to be who
I am but I don't solely think of myself
as a faceless representative of a racial
category
when I walk about in in my life and I'm
operating and doing things I I don't
think I am a white man doing all of
these things
like I'm like I'm some sort of agent
some sort of PR rep for whiteness
and so if I perceive myself to be
treated unfairly in a given situation
I will not automatically assume that the
treatment was racially based I will
cycle through any number of potential
explanations first I'll wonder if the
individual just doesn't like me
personally
you gotta think about that first like
it's it's if people are treating you a
certain way
uh maybe they just don't like you maybe
it's you that maybe you're the problem
or perhaps they're having a bad day or
perhaps they're simply incompetent or
perhaps uh you know perhaps you weren't
treated unfairly at all or perhaps any
number of other explanations and if
there is specific evidence that I was
the victim of racism then I'll take that
into consideration
I'm not going to rule it out
but of course it's not gonna be my first
assumption
it's not gonna be my first last and only
Theory because I'm aware that I am more
than a racial category and so is the
other person in the exchange and I'm
aware that life is complicated and
people are fueled by many different
kinds of motivations
but race Hustlers are conditioned or
have conditioned themselves
to see themselves
as nothing more than racial
representatives and to see everyone else
in the same light and to see every
interracial interaction as a contest
between those racial categories
that's why Mark Curry declared during
that exchange that a black man can't go
nowhere in America
because he sees himself as that a black
man just that just a black man not Mark
Curry okay not Mark Curry this isn't
happening to Mark Curry
they're doing this to Mark Curry he
didn't say that is this is simply a
black man just a generic black man
it's not Mark Curry being asked to
produce his room key it's a black man
being asked to produce his room key
that's how he sees it
or pretends to see it
because it is more profitable for him to
see life that way
indeed Mark Curry has not had much
success recently simply being Mark Curry
nobody cares much about Mark Curry or
wants to hear his lame stand-up comedy
but when he becomes a black man
generically that faceless representative
of a racial category
that's when he gets the attention he so
deeply craves
and that's what this is all about
and it's why Mark Curry
who happens to be a black man
is today canceled
and that'll do it for us for this
portion of the show as we move over to
the members block hope to see you there
if not talk to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]